hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on Luke universe comm thank
you and enjoy so we know that lipid
synthesis occurs mostly in the liver and
specifically in the endoplasmic
reticulum but how do these lipids that
are made there get transported to
tissues that need them because there are
tissues other than the livers tissues
that require lipids right lipids are
needed all over the body so how do they
get from the liver to those other places
well how does anything really get from
one organ to the next or one tissue to
the next it's through the blood the
blood carries nutrients sent it through
the through the body problem though
lipids are hydrophobic why is that a
problem well the blood is hydrophilic
right so I mean it's mostly water so how
do these lipids can't just travel
directly through the blood so what's the
solution
although these things called
lipoproteins or lipoprotein particles
and they transport lipids in the blood
so what are the different types of
lipoproteins Liz this chart down here
and we've got a few different types
we've got chylomicrons we've got V LDL
which stands for very low density
lipoprotein got IDL intermediate density
lipoprotein LDL low-density lipoprotein
and HDL high density lipoprotein we see
the density in diameter here density is
increasing going upwards this way and
diameter is decreasing going downwards
so chylomicrons are the biggest they are
the biggest and least dense and HDL are
the smallest and most dense of the
lipoproteins now another thing that's
important is the particle composition
why percent mass so what actually are
the components that make up a
lipoprotein and this the different ones
are ppl CC and T G one of those stand
for peas proteins
pls phospholipids C's cholesterol C II
is cholesterol esters and TGS
triglycerides so
this cholesterol here is free
cholesterol whereas seee cholesterol
esters we'll get into that in just a
second in fact let's do that now
cholesterol esters here we've got
cholesterol and here we got a
cholesterol ester really the difference
is right here
right here we have an H and the
cholesterol oops that's not that great
there we go got that Oh H there whereas
here we have an acyl group attached so
and to make this ester linkage here so
that acyl group can come from an acyl Co
a come from an acyl Co a of course the
coenzyme a will just fall off this
process is catalyzed by an enzyme called
a sub Co a cholesterol acyl transferase
venation makes sense we've got an acyl
coa here we've got cholesterol or
transferring an acyl group from the SOA
to cholesterol to make this cholesterol
ester the reason why this happens is
because once this collected we add this
acyl group to a cholesterol ester this
thing cannot escape the lipoprotein
whereas free cholesterol can okay so
these kind of will stay in the
lipoprotein particle now back up here I
do want to mention that the particle
composition by percent mass is pretty
important because it can help you
understand these functions here and I've
actually highlighted in green the
highest percentage or percentages by
particle by lipoprotein particle for as
far as what is contained within them so
chylomicrons here have mostly on there
85 86 percent triglycerides their
function is to deliver a dietary or
exogenous lipids mainly triglycerides so
what they do is they deliver a try or
assuming the lipids and especially the
triglycerides that we eat and are in our
diets to the cells and tissues that need
them VLDL they do a similar thing
they're also got lots of triglycerides
they deliver endogenous lipids which are
basically lipids that our body
synthesizes ourselves so again both of
these are mostly triglycerides it makes
sense that they're primarily
supporting triglycerides right IDL it's
got a bunch of cholesterol esters and
triglycerides in this case because it's
got both of those pretty high it's not
that useful and helping us determine
what it is in fact its function is just
as an LDL precursor we'll go into all
these different functions more detail
later I just want to cover them briefly
here
LDL mostly cholesterol esters its job is
to deliver cholesterol to the peripheral
tissues so it makes sense that it's got
a lot of cholesterol esters HDL is
mostly protein so that's the one that
gives you the least amount of help as
far as its actual function its function
is reverse cholesterol transport which
basically it's taking cholesterol from
the peripheral tissues back to the liver
so we're going to delve into all this in
more detail thank you for watching
thanks for watching be sure to LIKE
comment subscribe and don't forget to
share the video of anyone who you think
might find it helpful thanks and happy
studying